plenty of gardening is probably one of
the most important parts of developing a
garden location is important what you
want to grow is important
he brainstormed with the community what
do you want to grow how do you want to
grow what foods do you want it fosters a
culture of learning at all levels
everyone doesn't learn the same way so
we have to honor that respect that and
going into a community and playing the
garden around those principles and
understanding and you're using physical
soil but you also have this community
soil that also has to be taken care of
and continuously created and recreated I
think the most important part of the
garden is ensuring that the food is what
the community needs and the food is what
they want and then it's our job to make
sure that we provide like a design or
help them design it or exposing the
different designs with them choose what
design because the garden has to be well
designed to make sure we get the most
food out of it so this is also something
important to see the organization of a
community garden because this is
something that a facilitator would help
a community develop as in they would
help the community figure out how they
want something plots who wants to plant
word plant where actually sit down with
the community develop their own rules
and regulations although also if you're
in a city or in a certain County or a
town or community that already
regulations around land use so but still
trailer can help a community understand
the rules and regulations around land
use then also help them decide on how
they want to plan their garden and
organize these habits again this is a
like a facilitation method as in your
facilitating I'm a process between the
community and also the county in the
city in which it lives in and also the
structure and design of its ultimate
garden so if you already have a site
available you use that site and you grow
on that site but if you're going into a
community where they want to brainstorm
sites visibility is very important
because you want to attract diverse
people diverse communities and you want
to create again you're creating a space
for people to learn from each other as
well so
ability is very important but do you
want to go behind the tractor you think
about accessibility and if a community
accesses a certain space easier than
other spaces you want to choose an
easier space to access cuz food access
is not only just about social access but
it's also about physical access as well
you